Ah-chan, where is Eider?
Come on, it's going to be fast 3 It's definitely not good to shout loudly or chase after persistently
Ah,
that person was
acted by these guys
Hey, I can't predict
3 A good car
Really ribbon  You're so cute Yes, third place No matter
what you do, you can't run away after I'm
gone After I'm gone, I'll
bring out the small items like that
I'm scared of my spirit
Again, Abe White
Rom If this happens,
tan
[music]
Little people
, I'll protect you from that time Small children are weak, so Haru-chan, you're very quiet when you think you'll catch me
Bullying is against the rules, Ie-
chan  Ka-
Haru-chan doesn't seem to mind it, Narumi wants to be in charge too.